Speaker 1: OK, let's get into audience questions
first one very timely, very important, David,
the federal eviction moratorium is ending
soon. What is going to happen when all of
these people get evicted in the next few months?
Well, that's that's not going to happen, actually.
I think it's important to. Let's contextualize
it. Yes. I believe July 31st is actually the
day that the federal eviction moratorium
that's covid related will come to an end.
But there's a bunch of different reasons
which explain why you are not going to see
nearly even a majority of the people currently in
theory in at risk of getting evicted, get evicted.
Dean Baker, the economist, talked to us about this
last week. He said the number being bandied about
is about eight million people could get evicted,
but that he believes in reality it will be more
like 800000. And as he said, it doesn't mean
we don't care about the eight hundred thousand
but eight hundred thousand evictions nationally
is not necessarily going to be a major economic
disaster. Doesn't mean we don't care about the
people, doesn't mean we don't need to fix the
situation. So there's a few different things that
you have to remember. First of all, depending
on what state or even city you live in, the fact
that the federal moratorium guidance from the CDC
ends on July 31st doesn't necessarily impact
you because there are states and in some cases
even cities that are choosing different dates.
So there are already some states with moratoria
or moratoriums colloquially that
are in place that will go longer.
And two of the states or some of the states
with the largest populations like California,
Texas and New York, have protections that go
beyond July 31st already both for residential as
well as for business evictions. You've got other
states like Illinois, Oregon, Hawaii, New Jersey,
Washington, New Mexico. They have their own
guidelines in place that go longer than July 31st.
Texas has local eviction moratorium that has been
extended to, I believe it's October 1st or maybe
October 31st. So there's the idea that on a single
day all these people are going to get evicted. The
reality is many states have already extended that.
The other reality and this doesn't help people,
it's just from an economic shock perspective,
it's important. It takes a long time to evict
people and it takes a different amount of time
in different municipalities. It can take months
and months to evict people. I know various lawyers
that work on evictions, both with tenants and with
landlords. Often it's the same lawyers
that work with both, not in the same case,
but work with both. They say depending on the
state, you could take three to even six months,
depending on if it's a place where it gets cold
in the winter. There are even bigger restrictions
in place all the time. So there's not going
to be a single day of evictions. Now, one
additional factor here, California and
New York have announced programs where
they are going to pay past due rent for a lot
of people who are at risk of getting evicted.
So in those places, when the moratoriums finally
do end, there aren't going to be mass evictions
because the states have put in place these
programs. So for me, the bigger question
is the following. So many people live paycheck
to paycheck. You miss one paycheck, you miss
a payment for your rent. You can essentially
never catch up. There's an emergency. You've
got a health insurance plan with a two thousand
dollar deductible. And something happens where
you've got to pay the two thousand dollars
all at once. And so you miss a rent payment.
You essentially can never catch up.
And that is a bigger reality that
whatever you feel about paying past due rent, like
California, for example, put in place doing, even
if you feel like that's the right thing to do or
whatever, even getting a lot of people out of the
current situation. Imagine someone who's behind on
rent because of the pandemic, lost their job. Now
they're kind of keeping up, but they're not able
to catch up. They're going to end up statistically
anyway. Some percentage of them are going to end
up back in that situation anyway because so many
people are living paycheck to paycheck. That's not
going to change, even with rent forgiveness. The
last thought on this, there are people who say
that because real estate prices have become so
overblown in many parts of the country, that an
eviction and even a foreclosure crisis would be
a really good thing. It would pull down prices.
And that is not necessarily wrong in some states.
But there is a question as to whether we should
hope for the misery and stress and anxiety of
being evicted as a path towards a modest reduction
in housing prices, which may or may not even be
permanent. So that's kind of a bigger discussion,
but that's the bottom line on evictions,
they're not going to happen all at once, not that
many are actually going to take place. And you've
got to really pay attention to what's happening in
your state and in your municipality in particular.